now live from live near the border with
poland jonah so russian troops are now
in control of that nuclear plant what
can you tell us
so they say and that isn't being
contested by the ukrainian side so
we assume that is the case the russian
ministry of defense has come out and
said look these were attacks by
saboteurs uh essentially trying to stage
a ukrainian provocation uh by hitting
the site and that the russian forces
were stepping in to defend it
president zielenski by contrast calling
it nuclear terrorism
in the middle of all of this frankly not
concerned with the wise and wherefores
of what happened is the international
atomic energy agency in vienna concerned
principally with the safety of this site
and not just any old nuclear site that's
the biggest in europe it contains six of
the 15 nuclear reactors present present
in ukraine raphael mariano grossi the
head of the iaea held a press conference
just a short while ago in the last half
hour this was his update that there was
no release of radioactive material
as a result of the attacks on the fire
that burned for four hours in a training
building on the site the reactors he
said were not affected only one of them
was actually operational some held in
reserve some under repair some simply
switched off all systems he said
including radiation monitoring are fully
functional operating and working the
situation can you continues to be
extremely tense and
challenging he went on to describe the
key pillars of nuclear safety at these
plants the maintenance of security the
inviolability of these sites maintaining
supply lines maintaining staffing
maintaining critical communications he
said these were absolutely vital that
there needed to be an immediate meeting
well as soon as possible he said of the
two parties to recommit themselves to
these key pillars of safety at nuclear
power plants uh in ukraine he wants a
meeting of the russians and the
ukrainians at chernobyl that's his
suggestion
that is of course the nuclear power
plant which is just inside ukraine on
the
belarussian border he said he would head
that meeting and he said it was
absolutely imperative to maintain the
safety of these nuclear sites
jonah meanwhile the death toll is rising
around the country but particularly from
the attacks in chennai give us a picture
if you can across the rest of ukraine
uh awful strikes in chernyhev we've seen
dreadful pictures some very very
alarming
drone footage you know floating over
what is now a devastated town in the
north of the country no
verifiable no obvious military merit in
this in taking this town other than that
it happens to be on the line of russia's
advance from the north 47 dead civilians
of course the latest toll there the
focus of russia's attacks continues to
be on in the south along the black sea
coast we know that the towns of herson
fell yesterday berdyansk a smaller port
fell a couple of days ago
still holding out along that route
towards the eastern breakaway regions of
course the much bigger port city of
mario paul half a million people there
we've seen some very graphic imagery
coming out of the hospitals there but
frankly not a great deal coming out not
a great deal of visibility of what's
happening in there because this is a
city not only cut off from power and
heat but also from
internet and mobile communications it is
entirely surrounded it is under near
constant bombardment so we hear from the
mayor similar situation in kharkiv big
city in the east one and a half million
people there constant bombardment there
near constant at least and as i said
sharing this convoy continuing to cast
an awful presence close to the capital
kiev it has been stalled for about three
days now
with all sorts of problems besetting it
from logistical
problems supply problems morale problems
ukrainian resistance on its flanks the
suggestion that they are regrouping
reassessing resupplying and preparing to
continue here's my report wrapping up
the events of the last 24 hours
major ukrainian cities are surrounded
and under constant attack
this is chernihive a city of textile
factories churches and monasteries
its greatest misfortune to lie on the
root of russia's advance from the north
in the eastern city of kharkiv too
people wake daily to scenes of terrible
destruction and a fast rising civilian
death toll
look what pudding is doing
this is a war crime committed against
the civilians against
the city of kharkiv
this city of one and a half million
people most ethnic russians is being
torn apart by russian forces for no
reason other than that it exists just
across the border from russia in ukraine
and in the far south ukraine's biggest
port odessa
is under threat too
[Applause]
here frantic efforts have been underway
for days to build defenses against a
possible beach landing
multiple vessels belonging to russia's
black sea fleet hover on the horizon
including landing ships and support
craft
ukraine's military is very much still in
this fight reinforced by supplies of
weapons from abroad they've been able to
apply real pressure to the russian
advance slowing the progress of a vast
column of armor artillery and soldiers
heading for the capital kiev
along its route once sleepy commuter
towns lie in ruins a foretaste of what
may be in store for kiev the apparent
aim to encircle the city and besiege it
from his bunker under heavy guard
president vladimir zelensky wages a
relentless communications campaign
rallying resistance and calling in
foreign support
we have been saying this for a long time
that ukraine is seeking for protections
for our home soil and our own people but
such protections have not been provided
european countries assisted us with the
waves of migration however we should
discuss the guarantees that are required
to protect our country our home soil and
our people
a second round of talks on thursday
between russia and ukraine at a location
on the border with belarus came with low
expectations of a breakthrough but a
slim glimmer of hope that they're taking
place at all
[Music]
the ukrainian government meanwhile has
called for humanitarian corridors to be
set up and here in the western city of
alves volunteers are hard at work
processing aid donations medicines
clothes food and other essentials for
distribution across the country
there is a humanitarian crisis erupting
on multiple fronts not just the
internally displaced who've left
everything behind in a scramble for
safety across the country's borders as
more than a million have done since the
invasion began but also huge populations
in urban centers trapped terrified
and desperate for help
civilian morale will vary now in a
population increasingly terrorized
there'll be desperation in some places
determination in others
[Music]
a spontaneous rendition of the national
anthem at that aids station in uviv
it is becoming ever clearer that the
struggle is not just for personal
survival
but for the survival of the nation as a
whole
jonah al jazeera
[Music]
let's bring in samir puri in singapore
he is